voilà le playboy boris qui qui vient de
mettre ses lunettes ses lunettes de
soleil probablement pour ne pas souffrir
donc de la lumière des projecteurs
il a été surpris maurice là par la
chaîne une chose extrêmement confortable
et son adversaire qui s'installe
également christian bauer
on va laisser la parole à eloyes vosges
bonjour bonjour à tous donc bienvenue au
grand prix du sénat deuxième demi finale
donc on vous rappelle le résultat de la
première c'était le match joël lautier
contre laurent frayssinet et c'est
l'outsider laurent frayssinet qui l'a
emporté sur le score de 1-1 et demi 1/2
et donc il jouera la finale demain
contre le vainqueur de cette deuxième
demi finale donc qui opposera donc
christian bauer qui est à gauche qu'on
peut applaudir joueur de l'année 2000 à
monsieur donc à monsieur qu'on ne
présente plus champion du monde de 1969
à 1972 qui vient de trouver une chaise
monsieur boris spassky pourquoi
donc monsieur c'est parce qu'ils
proposent
sympathiquement agressant world de
changer également de chasse puisque
apparemment c'est plus stable
donc voilà donc dans cette partie
première partie boris vous aurez les
blancs christian bauer aura les noirs
match en deux parties en cas d'égalité
encore des plis de se départagent enfin
pour vous expliquer mieux le règlement
on va appeler monsieur larbitre arbitre
international thierry parisse donc genre
vous re précise le règlement nous allons
donc jouer un match aller retour c'est à
dire que christian bauer a joué la
première partie avec les noirs et la
seconde avec les blancs sur une cadence
de 22 minutes pour jouer la partie et à
chaque coup joué nous ajouterons deux
minutes sa part dans deux secondes et
non pas deux minutes 2 secondes à la
pendule en cas d'égalité donc
effectivement nous aurons une première
série de glisse de départage cinq
minutes par joueur
si nous avons à nouveau l'égalité une
seconde série 2 bis de départage
toujours cinq minutes
et si nous avons encore l'égalité nous
aurons un dernier blitz avec cinq
minutes pour les blancs 4 minutes pour
les noirs et obligations pour les blancs
de gagner voilà donc ce règlement donc
là il va y avoir la première partie
ensuite on fera une petite pause de dix
minutes avant la revanche et donc
ensuite effectivement swahili un gagnant
soit on a recours au départage donc on
va demander aux joueurs de nous dire
peut-être un petit mot sur le match donc
christian une analyse du jeu de boris
peut-être est-ce que tu as bien dormi
est ce que tu es en forme
oui je suis relativement forme c'est
difficile de se préparer contre boris
qui n'a plus beaucoup joué ces dernières
années mais bon je suis assez confiant
bien
boris le style de christian bauer jeune
no comments pas de commentaires avant la
partie donc je pense que nous allons
donner le coup d'envoi monsieur
l'arbitré
je crois que c'est parti pour cette
deuxième demi finale oui juste avant de
commencer je voudrais donc vous vérifiez
bien que vos écouteurs sont réglés au
minimum pour le volume comme
d'interviewer le jeu et surtout aussi
vérifier que votre téléphone portable
sont éteints nous allons donc je vais
donc lancé les pendules je vous demande
de faire plus grand silence merci
et voilà c'est parti pour cette deuxième
demi-finale entre boris spassky avec les
blancs et christian bauer et oui on a
gagné c'est bien deux françaises voilà
le hic donc c'est une française alors
sur des cinq cavalli c3 ou cavalli des
deux car alice et 3 voilà donc des
pronostics et qui fonctionne et la
question qui joue le coup le coup le
plus compliqué donc fou bekkat les
quatre qui al'avantage de plouay
lecavalier
voilà donc boris qui va probablement
rejouer ou 5
ça y est c'est fait cavalier e set a été
joué par christian cavalli hausse est
donc on attend probablement le ku'damm
g4 le coup le plus le plus compliqué ou
peut-être à 3 pour prendre la paire de
fou
food et 2 donc boris qui décide donc
dans cette position de jouer un vieux
coup un vieux coup un coût qui peut être
évite donc les lignes les plus
compliquées de cette position mais qui
de toute façon garde 20 kg et de toute
façon un coût extrêmement dangereux c5 a
été joué par christian qui contre
attaque au centre contre attaque sur le
centre christian un pion des 4 ici le
pion ces cinq attaques le pion des
quatre îles à il faut que gorille joue
probablement le coup à 2 à 3 ou 4 3 le
pdk est attaqué il faut boris peut
également aussi jouer cavalier c3 b5
donc pour échanger donc le foulée fouet
en même temps donc venir donc sur la
case sur la case des six essais ce coup
le cavalier venez sur la cause des
saints qui menacerait carélie des six
avec un échec qui des records et les
noirs donc la france est donc c'est une
ouverture ou les centres le centre de
pion est bloquée et les noirs auront
tout intérêt donc à un cas c'est donc
cette structure puisque le pion aux cinq
en avant poste permet en général donc de
développer des attaques assez virulente
sur le roi noir donc christian qui se
met comme il le fait à plusieurs
reprises dans une situation de contre à
gr iii il a joué voilà donc à 2 à 3 pour
prendre ces trois fous prendre ces trois
français trois fourgons c3 donc boris
qui ne veut pas à doubler ses pions
et là donc on attend probablement
cavaliers cavaliers des huit sait si
cela va laisser six pour contre attaquer
un petit peu sur le centre continue de
faire impression avec le pian et le
cavalier sur le centre voilà donc b6
donc christian qui joue bessette des six
son coût favoris dont il a l'intention
de christian et probablement des changes
et le fou de cases blanches en jouant
fous ces 8 à 6 c 8 assists pour échanger
avec le fouet f1 voilà donc et boris se
retrouverait donc uniquement avec le
foot est roi et il faudrait donc et
qu'il arrive à dynamiser ce fou donc
comme c'est une position ferme et ce
n'est pas si simple
mais bon la vence de développement lui
lui permettrait de le faire donc boris
qui réfléchit qui soit son cavalier qui
se développe donc en f3 coup très
logique donc beau risque continue son
développement
alors là christian peut jouer petit rock
ou x 6
la christian qui sommait la tête dans
les mains ils essayent de rentrer dans
la partie
je voulais donc ce type de position
contre boris ce n'est pas simple puisque
évidemment la française fait partie des
classiques aux échecs et borelli connaît
très très bien ce type de schéma boris
qui va probablement donc choisir un
développement harmonieux et pas vraiment
tranquille mais un développement plutôt
classique pour dans un premier temps
pour pour avoir des pièces très très
bien placé et peut-être après penser à
l'offensive sur le roi adverse
1 christian qui réfléchit va jouer là
prendre la position de duffort ouais il
a joué deux fois 6 voilà et bruisse
échange le fou voilà ça joue assez vite
ça joue simple boris se joue les coups
les plus simples tranquille boris un peu
comme un dernier joue assez vite des
coups simples il se prend pas trop la
tête boris oui tout à fait donc ce cas
valiant a six qui n'est pas pour
l'instant très très bien placé donc on
peut envisager donc plusieurs coups donc
petit rock ça y est christian qui
termine également son développement
petit rock
une position pas facile à jouer pour les
blancs avec ce fou c3 qui est enfermé
sur ses propres pions il tape sur ses
propres pions pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de jeu se fout ça va être le
problème des blancs d'essayer de trouver
du jeu
tours donc boris qui continue son
développement la tour donc qui qui
pourra entrer dans le vif du sujet un
peu plus tard peut-être de jouer sur la
case de 3 pour après coulisses et ici
sur la troisième rangée pour viser le
rock adverse
c'est possible
elle défend également le pion aux 5 ce
qui permettrait donc sur une prise une
éventuelle prise en d4
la prise du cavalier éventuellement donc
le pur de 5 sera défendu par la tour en
vain donc c'est un coût qui offre aux
blancs plus de possibilités à l'avenir
et là donc comme dans cette phase de jeu
donc dans l'ouverture christian qui doit
absolument trouver le bon plan peut-être
aussi que les ce cavalier à 6 ce serait
possible de le ramener sur la case b8 et
en c6 c'est peut-être un peu long quand
ces six le cavalier noir serait
idéalement placé puisqu'il contrôlerait
les quatre centrales des 4 et le 5 et le
cavalier e set pourrait lui venir sur la
case f5
il a joué cavalier sur la case g6
christian donc christian qui joue
cavalier g6
il joue vite boris adoubé 4 pour forcer
les blancs à choisir you b4 pour mettre
la pression sur le pion c5 pour obliger
les noirs et voilà dans une décision
boris qui joue un coup très logique
puisque bekkat donc finalement c'est la
meilleure solution pour faire jouer ce
fou se fout de gaze noire le fou c3
c'est vrai qu'après avoir échangé deux
pions en c5 le four et tout d'un coup
plus de possibilités on voit que dans
cette position de la prise du plan b 4
par le pion noire serait catastrophique
puisque elle ouvrirait la colonne b pour
la tour a un qui pourrait exercer une
certaine pression sur le pion à 7 donc
bekkat un coup très très logique qui qui
créé directement un conflit donc juste à
côté du centre de l'échiquier sur la
case c5
voilà alors qu'on a un plan des deux
joueurs les joueurs en jeu est assez
vite surtout maurice c'est bruce qui
vous le plus vite et il met la pression
monte à embrouilles
boris très appliqué sur cette partie
pour ces 8 a été joué par christian huit
ans qui prend pas de décision quant à
son pion ses sacres préfère maintenir la
pression au centre le protège par sa
tour
donc boris qui élimine beaucoup de
contresens noir probablement il peut
prendre en c5 avec le pion b et sur des
français 5
il peut peut-être essayer d'installer
une tour sur la colonne b la colonne
ouverte pour b 1
vous continuez donc son développement
dam des deux donc boris y continue donc
son développement
tam d2 un coup très subtil dans cette
position puisque boris attend donc la
réaction des noirs évidemment le
cavalier ne peut pas quitter la casa 6
pour l'instant puisque le pion 5
seraient perdus et le pion noir donc le
pion c5 ne peux pas trop bouger dans
cette position dans christian on va
peut-être devoir augmenter donc son
contrôle de la colonne c'est peut-être
en jouant un coup comme d'hab c'est 7
mais ce serait peut-être une erreur à
cause d'eux à cause de b 4 des 5 donc
peut-être dame 17 alors qu'adam 17 pour
coordonner les tours et si on doit
terminer son développement au plus vite
traoré noter que pour l'instant on voit
pas trop où va se passer l'action pour
l'instant il ya juste une pression sur
l'option ces cinq mais pas suffisante
puisque les deux pions ici son canton
carré par le plan b 6 lecavalier à six
et la tour s'est vite ça fait beaucoup
de défenseurs cavaliers h4 est également
un coup intéressant pour les graves dans
cette position pour peut-être essayer
d'éliminer donc ce cavalier en f3 pour
essayer donc d'éliminer le cavaliere f3
qui qui contrôle le centre alors que le
cavalier angers 6 lui pour l'instant
deux n'est pas très utile
ce sera un échange intéressant puisque
après cavaliers pros hkd dame proche cat
les tours noir se retrouvent liées elles
peuvent rentrer dans le jeu beaucoup
plus vite et en même temps la dame en h4
et exerce une petite pression sur le
plan des cats donc cabaye h4 un coup
intéressant qu'est ce qui va nous
trouver christian là
peut-être si tu de cavaliers à 6 sur le
gaz belvito si c'est possible et
beaucoup de flèches cavaliers 8 oui mais
il y aurait peut-être des prix dans ces
cinq ce serait peut-être un peu tôt dont
cavalière coach je pense que ce sera un
bon coup
laboris et sera une joute très vite il a
joué très vite tous ses coups treize
coups joués en moins d'une minute
alors qu'il reste président qui jouent
lentement donc il nous avait habitués
donc aussi un jeu assez lent à la coupe
du monde deux parties rapides et qui lui
avait fait défaut mais bon c'est vrai
qu' il vaut mieux partir avec une bonne
position
le temps
le
donc déjà quatre minutes d'avancé pour
les blancs et christian qui joue dams et
7 18 minutes il reste aux blancs contre
14 en noir ça prouve bien que maurice
joue très vite et que ça risque de jouer
sur la fin de la partie
dames c'est cette fougue les deux le
four revient sur les cases b2 police
enlève de la colonne il fait bien mais
l'un est ce que les noirs maintenant on
ne pourrait pas prendre deux pions parce
que lecavalier a6 sera attaquée par la
tour 1 quoique pions prendre les 4 as
l'air de son visage est donc pu
reprendre 4 on peut l'envisager mais il
y aurait quand même pu on prend des
quatre qui qui exploiterait
immédiatement la colonne ouverte et
lecavalier serait attaqué ce qui serait
désagréable là le plan de boris est
simple maurice va probablement jouer c2
c3 et après donc sur une prise en d4 il
prendrait du pion à onfray jouer sa tour
et sur une prise en d4 ils prendraient
d'une pièce de la dame probablement je
vais dame de france et deux noms avec à
pioncer 3 non ce ne serait plus possible
sur ces 3
voilà avec un petit piège c'est qu'après
les v8 il a joué cavalier b8 donc évite
le petit piège c'est après ces trois pu
reprendre les quatre cavaliers prend des
cats sur cavaliers prend le 5 à le piège
ne marche pas il y aurait peut-être
cavaliers b5
enfin une position compliquée
voilà donc boris qui joue c3 c3 s en
fout et complète pas enfermer ça c'est
un problème se fout là il est
complètement mort - boris qui enferme
son fou donc il a confiance dans son
centre et ils préfèrent donc consolider
son centre au péril donc du jeu du fou
du foot de cases noires c'est un choix
quand même assez à ses responsables
on se demande dans la cabine ce que ce
que vaut cette décision ouais c'est
curieux ce coup c3 qui enferme le four
b2 et de l'autre côté la position est
très fermé on voit pas trop comment les
noirs pourrait passer
oui la position de toute façon la
position blanche restent extrêmement
solides
c'est vrai
et de toute façon ces deux joueurs ne
n'ont pas peur de jouer une position
très ferme et plus plus fermé que la
position de tout à l'heure puisque dans
la deuxième partie jouée laurent
frayssinet contre joël lautier la
position c'était un petit peu ouverte et
là dans cette position elle aurait
plutôt tendance à se fermer
ce qui donne très peu de champ d'action
aux pièces oui là c'est des choix
stratégiques à longue portée faut faire
attention structure de pions ne pas ne
pas casser ces structures de pions et
essayer de voir après des échanges ce
que peuvent donner les finales il ya
christian bauer prend du retard à la
pendule il reste onze minutes contre 17
à boris spassky il prendre six minutes
de retard et oui donc
boris qui est immobile pour l'instant on
peut dire que les hostilités n'ont pas
été engagées c'est vrai
trouver des coûts inutiles dans cette
position c'est très difficile
et christian bauer se demande bien ce
qui va pouvoir jouer c'est bien joué de
la part de boris finalement une pose de
gros problèmes à christian en jouant des
coups simples très rapidement et met la
pression autant il ya une énorme
confiance boris danse à son intuition
christian qui doit quand même se poser
la question est ce que je dois fermer ou
pas puisque en jouant ce sens que ces
quatre le four b2 ne jouerait plus
pendant un petit bout de temps et les
blancs auraient quand même à leur
disposition le coût à 3 à 4 pour essayer
de le faire jouer par la case à 3 on
peut aussi s'interroger sur le couple
reprend des quatre qui est un coup très
intéressant puisque c'est prend des cats
ne semble pas donné grand chose les
noirs occupe très très bien la colonne c
est si on prend du cavalier le pion aux
cinq risquent de tomber
donc il faudrait prendre de la dame
ce qui n'est peut-être pas
extraordinaire donc qui comprend des
cartes un coup très très intéressant
pour les noirs aussi plan prend des cats
qui fut de reprendre avec l'opinion on
pourrait reprendre avec le pion mai
mais les noirs dans cette position donc
vont peut-être après dégager la colonne
s'est placé par exemple lors dame en c4
ou quelque part où on bessette et placé
leur tour en place et les tours noir sur
la connaissez je prends décote et qu'un
coup très intéressant
christian qui prend vraiment beaucoup de
retard à la pendule et oui donc c'est
curieux sa position ne semble semble
tout à fait correct donc une réflexion
exagéré voilà puis reprend des quatre le
bon coup puis on prend des cats
et dame ces deux voilà christian qui qui
va essayer donc de profiter de son
avance de développement sur la colonne
c'est pour transposer dans une finale où
il se retrouvait avec un petit avantage
donc dams et 2
et boris est revenu en c1 donc
finalement c'était une sorte d'aveu donc
boris avoue que son placement n'est
peut-être pas idéal sans placement de
fonds en b2 il replace son fou oui je
crois tout simplement que boris donc n'a
pas très confiance dans son ouverture et
maintenant ils décident de se retrancher
dans des des schémas plus défensifs pour
essayer de tenir la position à quatre
coups très intéressant puisque le fou
c'est en va revenir sur la diagonale à 3
et fuite où il sera beaucoup plus utile
un petit avantage tout de même quand
même pour le joueur nancéen christian
bauer
qui d'ores et déjà montre ce que la
nouvelle génération est capable de faire
dans des positions très technique
le montre mais il est un peu lent il est
même très très long boris n'a pas l'air
en confiance on l'a vu à l'écran là donc
un petit peu soucieux quand même voilà à
à 6-5 ou très curieux à 6
probablement pour fermer la position
mais boris a peut-être le coût des
quatre des cinq dans sa position car si
les blancs ne joue pas becca de beyssac
c'est les noirs qui peuvent le faire des
quatre dessins qui donnerait voilà b4 b5
c'est ce qu'a joué boris donc qui fait
jouer sont fous ces 1 à nouveau donc le
fou qui et qui s'est retrouvé enfermé il
ya quelques il ya quelques il ya
quelques coups on retrouve petit à petit
du jeu
donc que veut faire le joueur de nancy
donc après b 4 des 5
il va devoir faire un choix responsable
dans cette position oui bertrand comment
se débarrasser un jour de la tow de la
dame ces deux parce que c'est quand même
ça lépine jeu des blues il a déjà donc
c'est parce qu'il ya déjà fait d un
effort pour rendre meilleurs s'en fou
noir on s'en fout on s'en fout c'est un
qui travaillera celui d'avoir mais
maintenant comment comment sont battus
pour essayer plutard de déloger cette
dame aubin tout simplement en jouant fou
à 3 donc x 3 qui risquent de d'arriver
rapidement et après en jouant la tour e
en c1 donc pour chasser tout simplement
cette dame donc le x 3 va peut-être
s'installer sur la case des 6 également
j'ai l'impression que le coup à six et
un coup à coup très curieux beaucoup des
noirs 5 ou qui ne sont pas très utiles
et qui permet aux blancs finalement de
replacer de rentrer dans la partie
parce que ce fou ne demandait qu'à jouer
et il fallait il fallait être très
rapide avec les noirs et après après
quatre des cinq la position il devient
très très compliqué surtout que le fonds
des six va vraiment être très dangereux
voilà boris qui met son foin à 3 donc x
3 qui attaquent la tour en f18
alors content c'est catastrophique
puisque boris il lui reste 15 minutes
contre à peine 5 pour christian donc
c'est ça va être terrible
christien a vraiment beaucoup réfléchi
et ça risque de lui coûter cher en fin
de partie
l' avantage maurice on peut dire
davantage bourhis à cause du temps
notamment et l'a réussi à activer son
fou en plus alors hier souviens toi
souvenez-vous jean luc et stéphane
bourhis a dit qu'ils pouvaient jouer
maintenant vie sans éclat main alors
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu dire exactement
parce qu'on aimerait bien pouvoir jouer
simplement avec norman oui on en a parlé
donc
et boris donc qui est un joueur qui a
une expérience incroyable il a une
carrière de quarantaine d'années déjà
peut-être même plus cinquantaine
d'années ça fait 50 ans qu'ils jouent
aux échecs donc pour lui le jeu n'a plus
beaucoup de secrets il est capable de
jouer avec son intuition et de jouer des
coups très très fort rebond dans cette
partie on va pas dire qu'il a joué des
coups très très fort dans un premier
temps il s'est contenté de défendre la
position et dans un deuxième temps donc
il a et dans un deuxième temps donc il
il a replacé son fou sur la diagonale à
3 et fuite et pour obtenir donc cette
finale où tout va se jouer sur la
colonne c mais ce fou à 3 va
probablement s'installer sur la case des
six le pion b6 risque d'être faible
et c'est pour ça que christian donc
maintenant décide de faire la réaction
classique donc de cette défense
française c'est la réaction au centre
quand on commence à être un petit peu
menacé il faut trouver un petit peu de
jeux pour ses pièces et en jouant fcf 6
en attaquant trois fois le pion aux 5
il va essayer d'obtenir un centre
puissant c'est qu'il lui donnerait donc
des contres chance boris donc n'a pas
envie que crise on joue au centre très
prophylactiques et ils préfèrent ils
préparent donc la montée du pion en f4
mais est ce que est ce que tout et
j'imagine que vous avez déjà parlé de ça
tout à l'heure j'étais pas arriver du
est ce que le mauvais fait ce que le fou
à 3 toujours pas mauvais à cause de la
structure centrale qu'en penser parce
que c'est quand même une position très
technique
allons ce fou à 3 est un excellent fou
maintenant il est excellent c'est un
excellent fou puisque le x 3 donc
contrôler une diagonale
diagonale à 3 et fuite qui qui est très
très importante stratégiquement en plus
il peut bondir sur le plan b 6 à
n'importe quel moment en via la case des
six il peut aller ans et 7 et il va
aider activement donc l'occupation de la
colonne sait puisque ce qui est curieux
c'est que je parle d'occupation de la
colonne s'est pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune tour blanche sur la colonne s'est
pourtant ils ont un ascendant très
important c'est qu'ils peuvent doubler
facilement sur la colonne c'est parce
que le fond à 3 contrôlerait cette
colonne c est ce que est ce que le plan
de ce pass qui je parle d'un plan de
mettre une tour en c1 et après deux
montées le roi oui donc déjà il concède
attention donc sur tour ces deux là
boris va jouer cavalier f3 et maintenant
donc boris s'apprête à très vite à
maurice il s'apprête à récupérer cette
colonne sépare tour océans et il m'est
vraiment beaucoup de pression montant
beaucoup de pression autant il reste 3
minutes 30 à christian bauer à peine
qu'il active et donc christian qui va
rester donc avec ce petit pion en b 6
voilà en bref c'est un coup très logique
tour c'est un tour c'est 8
et maintenant que veut faire boris donc
nous pourrions sauver le roi sur la
casse d un oui boris ton qui peut jouer
rouaroua f1 suivi droits humains il peut
peut-être aussi échanger les tours et
proposait donc un échange général de
tours c'est ce qui fait c'est ce qui
fait alors maintenant cette finale il
peut jouer tout autour à deux peut-être
mais c'est de rester à l'air d'être
dangereux tour à 2,1 à ce que les toits
deux mènent à une position très
compliqué donc sur tours à deux je pense
que les blancs et si c'était peuvent
jouer fou des six exactement dont fou
des six est sacrifié le pion mais après
essayer de profiter donc dû clouage du
cavalier en 17 partout recettes par tour
c'est cette voie là donc christian qui a
le choix entre échanger des pièces ou
obtenir une finale légèrement inférieur
il est très mal autant christian il est
très mal autant oui c'est un élément
très important stéphane on l'a on a bien
d'avoir deux minutes train non
6 oh là là et font bien pour boris tu
arrives à lire treize minutes
enfin et milieu tu assures je suis sûr
je vais demander confirmation donc on
demande confirmation mais de toute façon
ces deux minutes peuvent être compensées
par une facilité d'accélération
que da peut-être pas boris donc la
question c'est boris va-t-il jouer au
foot des six bref au dé sitôt reprend
1,4 pour ses sets mais c'est ça c'est
deux minutes il reste 3 8l 5 la la il
joue c'est ivry joue vraiment solide un
beau et c'est donc boris qui ne prend
aucun risque
il reste très peu de temps à tristan il
faut qu'ils jouent vite h5 qu'il a joué
bourhis qu'il n'est pas venu non quand
on sait 7 alors qu'est ce que tu penses
j'en reviens maintenant parce qu'il est
tout le temps de le jouer sur food et
six tours pour un 4 tours c728 3 8l 5
et puis on prend 1,6
oui c'est possible qu'en penses tu
jean-luc oui ça semble très très fort
dans cette position ça semble vraiment
être le coup mais boris a joué h3 donc
boris qui ne veut pas qu'ils ne veut pas
conclure très curieux très très curieux
boris qui qui prend qui reprend ses
mauvaises habitudes donc comme on l'a vu
donc de ne pas terminer les parties donc
oui mais il a tout son temps alors que
christian a eu lui reste deux minutes
une minute maintenant une minute trente
non si will you qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
qu'est-ce qui se passe d'ailleurs il
commence à s'agiter sur sa chaise si on
voit là bas il sent que il va falloir
qu'ils jouent là problème c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de coups lien du gringue
presque christian bauer cavaillé fuite
et oui cavalli gf huit noms clisson qui
doit consolider donc qui doit de tenir
son c'est la position de ses cavaliers
c'est plus ou moins la seule chose qui
lui reste et voilà et boris donc qui
plutôt que de choisir donc un plan un
plan direct choisi un plan indirects l'a
probablement il s'apprête à placer son
cavalier sur la case c2 où il enferme la
tour en 1 2 oui donc qui avait lieu à
ces deux cas les havrais avaient fait
roi f213 b12 c 1 à 2 c ça rappelle à
tout va il pas attraper la toile est si
il ya l'air de pouvoir attraper la toa
non666 donc incroyable hi hi hi ha oui
mais s'est attardé il veut jouer g5
christian oui
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué comme elle et ses
deux oui il va prendre la toile donc
boris qui enferme la tour attendant tu
sais pas si simple il veut aller en
quatre questions wave 2 oui je l'aï joué
tous les coups la wave 2 il peut jouer
les coucous match 4 aussi h4 voilà il
vient d'envoyer et voilà donc c'est vrai
show fait ça va chauffer christian iv
assez incroyable cergy 4 échecs g4 qui
gagne sur trois projets quatre fous
c'est un échec
et sur quoi faire tour 3 non non il n'ya
pas le match mais découverte et le oui
exactement donc le roi doit revenir et
maintenant le roi peut se rapprocher de
lille à entendre la tour tranquille
c'est une partie incroyable il a joué 3
f 5 donc la seule chance pour prescience
c'est de créer un déséquilibre aller
droit donc le pion g va peut-être
avancer
qu'est ce qu'il a fait un an boris se
rapproche de la tour et oui oui on va le
jouer ce plan roye b un airois droit
c'est un airois c'est fantastique
non il revient de toute façon il défend
le puits ils bloquent le pion h il va
prendre la tour dans deux coups il l'a
mis un succès one boris incroyable il va
jouer le roi amène on met la vie croît
c'est trois rois b3 et la tourelle
prison il a joué avec une toile a tout
simplement incroyable donc quand boris
n'a pas voulu monter son fut indécise
c'était parce qu'il avait déjà vu donc
voilà ça ce sera vidé pour enfermer la
tour ça joue très vite trois bien ça y
est la tour est prise
et oui ça y est il a pris la qualité
boris et il va prendre le pion g7
quelle partie
quelle partie la gare voilà si c'était
un très bon ça c'est ça c'est quand même
pas mal hein
et oui c'est ce qu'on appelle jouer avec
la main
c'est ça il a joué très vite bon et bien
superbe victoire de boris enfin belle
victoire boris un petit commentaire
donc on a pu entendre vériste yupeek
game tout de suite donc en tout cas une
très très belle victoire de boris dans
cette première partie
bon les joueurs sont en train de
commenter mais il semblerait que donc
cette française soit bon et est
probablement égal mais finalement la
pression autant n'a pas enfin a fait la
différence puisque christian bauer a
réfléchi beaucoup beaucoup et à la fin
eh bien il a fait des fautes inévitable
donc eh bien on va laisser les deux
joueurs sortir se mettre en condition
pour la deuxième partie qui aura lieu
dans une petite dizaine de minutes donc
l'enjeu très simple bon espace qui aura
les noirs aura la possibilité de faire
nul pour gagner le match
christian bauer lui il sera obligé de
marquer le point pour revenir au score à
deux partout donc ça sera tout l'enjeu
de cette prochaine partie donc je vous
invite pendant 10 minutes vous détendre
les joueurs se reposent et donc retour
dans une petite dizaine de minutes pour
la deuxième partie de la demi finale
merci
ah oui mais
alors stephen décombres un un beau un
beau un bon premier match et puis une
belle feinte bon premier set
enfin boris avait les blancs donc on
peut penser que christian va va essayer
de mieux faire dans la deuxième partie
visiblement là il s'est fait justement à
peu faire fait battre à la main je sais
pas ce que tu en penses parce qu'ils
avaient une bonne position c'est au
sortir de l'ouverture ah oui mais le
mais le vieux lion il a tord il a joué
très vite surtout incroyable c'est
christian n'a vraiment pas joué à la
cadence c'est important à ce niveau là
de jouer vite et oui enfin je vais vous
lire notre ami stéphane n'a pas n'a pas
des jeunes et donc il est obligé de se
ressourcer là est en train de manger un
excellent sandwich nom que vous dire de
plus sur cette partie que
malheureusement j'ai pas vu depuis le
début que c'était certainement une
française oui donc une partie typique
très difficile à jouer avec des
structures de pions figé
où effectivement un moment donné on l'a
vu ce parce qu'ils avaient un mauvais
fou parce que ce faux buter contre sa
structure de pions mais qu'il a joué
c'est une partie à partir d'un certain
degré de la partie quand il a joué
vraiment d'une manière tout à fait
classique un exemplaire il a joué que
des coups avec à quatre baies v4 v5 pour
essayer de redonner de la vie à ce fou à
ce fou et c'est comme ça qu'on joue et
puis après vous avez vu tous les coups
qui sont venus une manoeuvre assez assez
assez rigolotes pour enfermer la tour
toutes les perceptions une une petite
pointe tactique quand
quand restions a voulu a voulu rentrer
que son roi un oui mais ça c'est des
petites pointes qu'il faut pas oublier
parce que sinon il aurait certainement
eu un bon contre je vois là on a plus
maintenant qu'à attendre cette deuxième
partie et puis espérons que que
christian puisse égalise et non pas
parce qu'on soutient c'est parce que
tout simplement on a envie qui est du
qui est un beau départager c'est
évidemment en égalisant la seule manière
d'arriver au tie-break que l'on n'a pas
vu aujourd'hui
souvenez-vous nous l'an passé ce parce
qu'ils s'étaient qualifiés in extremis
contre arnaud hauchard après avoir fait
nul 5
cette fois ce qu'ils avaient fait nul
ils avaient fait nul dans les deux
parties semi-rapides puis dans les deux
parties deux parts parties de blitz
puis les deux nouveaux partis de beats
et enfin il avait joué le fameux blitz
de départage le penalty 5 4 à 5 minutes
pour les blancs quatre minutes pour les
noirs avec obligation pour les blancs de
gagner et de nouveaux chars n'avait pas
pu forcer la position et boris s'était
qualifié pour jouer la finale face à 6
shirov en ne gagnant pas une seule une
seule partie alors c'est la première
partie qu'il gagne ici au sénat danse
dans un style au fond de sénateurs dont
la venue on pense et on voulait qu'on
qui joue les coups très très agressif
pour finir la partie et puis il a joué
d'une manière très
encore une fois très classique pour
confirmer la tour du malheureux
christian qui avait fait l'erreur de
jouer un peu lentement alors on attend
là visiblement ce pas ce qui a l'air
quand même il est c'est vrai que c'est
un joueur qui est à la retraite mais
stéphane et jean luc ont certainement dû
vous le dire il a joué beaucoup ces
temps ci puisqu'il a participé au
tournoi anniversaire de kornoi qui
fêtait ses 70 ans la semaine dernière à
zurich un tour notre prestigieux qui
réunit c'est évidemment encore jeune
mais aussi
kasparov aussi krainik le nouveau
champion du monde est
des vieilles gloires comme le grand
maître allemand rüdiger les quatre
meilleurs joueurs suisses hugues
lepeltier et
et cetera et puis ce vide l'air y avait
short il y avait vraiment c'est un très
beau tournoi espace qui a s'est quand
même qualifié pour les quarts de finale
et n'a perdu contre shirt que dans
l'église de départage ça prouve que
quand il veut s'en donner la peine il
est encore capable de très bien jouer et
sont seuls des videmment son seul défaut
aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir peut-être
effectivement peut-être moins d'énergie
qu'il y a qu il ya de ça vingt ou trente
ans au moment de sa gloire c'est à dire
les années 60 70 au moment où il jouait
les championnats du monde alors je vous
rappelle quand même s'est il était
champion du monde junior boris il a été
une première fois finaliste en 66 et du
championnat du monde face à tigran
petrossian dit le tigre dit le joueur le
joueur béton un perdre une partie par an
et puis la rejouer une finale en 69 face
à ce même petit grain de petrossian qui
l'a gagné avec un jeu très brillant
c'était un joueur universelle c'est
parce qu'il ya un joueur qui joue les
joueurs d'échecs disent qu'ils aquila le
beau jeu et puis il a joué ce fameux
match de championnat du monde en 1972 à
reykjavik
entre son son je dirais son meilleur
ennemi bobby fischer les deux hommes
effectivement été certainement c'était
le match d'échecs le plus médiatisé
après il ya eu des matchs médiatisé
après que karpov korshunov en soixante
dix huit après il ya eu les cards les
fameux karpov kasparov lé karpov
kasparov
mais c'est vrai que ce parce qu'ils
fischer avait défrayé la chronique en 72
pour des mauvaises raisons
savait attirer la grande presse parce
que ici imaginait que le l'américain
fisher était le représentant du
capitalisme américain et le russe
spassky représentants du régime
soviétique en réalité c'était tout à
fait faux tout ça a été tout à fait
manichéen et les deux hommes avaient une
grande estime et une grande amitié
la preuve est bien puisqu'ils ont rejoué
un match bon soir vingt ans après nous
allons temps après comme dans les
nouvelles d'alexandre dumas voile alors
prêt loi voilà nous avons donc reprendre
dans cette deuxième partie à l'eiblen
hilal et blanc ils jouent contre boris
parce qu'il a perdu la première partie
donc boris parce qu'il mène par 1 à 0
pour revenir dans le match il doit
impérativement gagner cette partie donc
22 minutes chacun deux secondes d'ajouts
supplémentaires par coup
christian bauer boris spassky la
revanche tout de suite monsieur
l'arbitré à mettre les pendules en route
et on vous souhaite un très bon match
donc à nouveau les consignes vérifiez
bien volume de votre casque soit pas
trop c'est trop fort sur tous les
téléphones portables voilà le silence je
démarre
des 5es d'être relayée alors je vais
laisser la place à jean louis chabanon
qui va revenir va être votre
commentateurs principal voilà donc une
surprise
voorhees qui en général jouhaud 4,5 sur
la joue et f3 qui joue au cateau 5 il a
donc à jouer donc une une carreaux
cannes et christian sortent des sentiers
battus en jouant f3 et la position fait
très compliqué cette fois donc boris qui
doit faire match nul pour gagner cette
deuxième demi finale
il a joué une variante très très très
logique donc pour l'instant ça ressemble
donc à une position donc delà de la
moderne avec c'est à dire la moderne et
une ouverture où on met directement le
fou ancien ghetto le fou angers7 le foot
cases noires ça ressemble un petit peu à
une position comme ça où donc les blancs
dans pour l'instant consolident leur
centre
ce qui est très logique avec f3 et la
position risque de se faire mais
peut-être à n'importe quel moment en
tout cas de christian qui va essayer de
revenir au score
ça promet beaucoup pour cette deuxième
demi-finale distance adam très tôt comme
les débutants attaquant le pion b2 et
christian jour répond immédiatement dam
des deux un coup très logique d'un des
deux camps qu'ils sacrifient le courant
et voorhees le prend et boris le prend
forcément donc après pu reprendre des
cinq je pense que boris n'a peut-être
pas l'intention de reprendre des 5 mai
de tout simplement terminer son
développement à l'est le roi il faut que
bertrand il faut que pardon il faut que
christian joue plus vite que la première
partie
oui donc christian qui va probablement
accélérer la cadence
puis on prend des 5es laboris va
probablement jouer un coup comme
cavalier f6 oui peut-être
à moins qu'il accepte le challenge total
donc la prison des cinq noms cavaliers
si c'est plus est plus judicieux donc
boris qui rend le pion mais qui
maintenant on va se retrouver avec un
jeu de pièces assez assez agréable
puisque les blancs sont mal développés
on peut déjà dire donc après cette
ouverture que les noirs sont peut-être
déjà un peu mieux donc lappion prend c6
est intéressant mais se remettre de
développer le cavalier avec anne de
temps ça permet donc le développement du
cavalier mais c'est quand même compliqué
puisque après cavaliers prend ses six il
y aurait peut-être cavaliers b5 et dames
3 2 et d'un pra de exactement donc une
suite possible dans cette position en
tout cas ils vont pas manquer ce que
pense à ça ça c'est le jeu que tu aimes
ça quand même
oui ça va être la chauffe beaucoup plus
vivant dans cette partie quand m quoique
la première était vraiment de toute
beauté pour l'instant on assiste à deux
très belles demi finale voilà donc
christian qui joue à tout coup très
logique floue sekkat et il s'apprête
donc à terminer son développement par
cavalier j'ai eu de suivi de petit rock
donc boris qui s'enflamme un peu mais
ils doivent se méfier car son adversaire
est redoutable dans les positions vertes
il est capable de petit road très
logique donc boris qui termine son
développement il joue très vite et là
christian qui va voilà qui termine aussi
cavalier chez eux 2 suivi de petit rock
vous plus vite que dans la première il a
compris la leçon
donc créé une leçon christian là il a
pris une leçon de jeu rapide il faut
jouer vite les coups sous peine de se
retrouver dans une grosse difficulté
autant voilà donc maintenant
boris va devoir trouver de voir tout
terminer son plan probablement peut-être
tour des huit dans cette position pour
placer la tour en phase donc du pion des
cinq éditions descartes et de l'adam d2
et pour provoquer une réaction
oak de la part de christian tour des
huit qui menacerait probablement pu
reprendre des 5 ha non boris qui prend
qui a pris le pion des cinq directement
faut calculer est-ce que tu disais tout
à l'heure c'était des cavaliers bessac
intermédiaire que se passe-t-il la
cavalier b5 intermédiaire il faudrait
jouer damas quatre se semble être le
seul coup mais boris qui a quand même
sous-estimer ce coup cavalli et b5
non il pourrait jouer aussi peut-être
autre chose des cinq damas six cavaliers
c'est cette dame français 4 et sacrifier
la qualité
oui mais donc oui tout à fait mais oui
c'est vrai donc peut-être cavaliers
prendre des cinq tout simplement
personnellement je chez l'impression que
les noirs sont déjà un petit peu mieux
puisque les pions les pions des les
plans c'est son sang sur les colonnes
ouverte
c'est ce qu'on appelle donc des pions
pendant et et le roi blanc n'est pas
développé pour l'instant le roi blanc
est toujours au centre décennale et les
noirs sont toujours bien voilà un
tournoi fait pour les noirs là christian
est en train de réfléchir
il aimerait bien compliquer la position
mais ce n'est pas si simple car il a
pris in africa va les prendre des 5 il a
pris donc du cavalier
et boris donc doit être en train de
trouver une stratégie donc pour calmer
le jeu et placer ses pièces donc face à
ces face à ses pions des cats et c'est
de terminer son développement avant tout
voilà donc cavalier prend fou prend et
cavaliers c6 le plus simple donc boris
n'a pas peur de france ceci s'il
reprendrait du pion et sa paire de fou
pourrait jouer donc très activement le
fond g7 sur la grande diagonale et le
fond ces huit qui se verrait donc la
possibilité d'aller sur la case à 6 par
exemple où la gaze e6 une très belle
case aussi
jouer qu'est-ce qu'il faut jouer petit
rock maintenant qu'en penses tu avec les
blancs quand même petit rôle intéressant
mais tour dix huit tours des 8 est quand
même très désagréable plaçant la tour
face aux pions des cats avec le fou g7
le cavaly c6 et la tour des huit le pion
des cats
déjà en difficulté christian cancé deux
parties ben oui dont on légère
difficulté parce que bon ce n'est que le
début il peut il peut se refaire mais vu
l'excellente forme de boris actuellement
ça semble quand même assez difficile
et oui et oui comme on le voit à l'écran
ceux ci on n'est pas satisfait on
retrouve un boris là qu'on n'avait pas
vu depuis longtemps
arc-bouté devant l'échiquier les mains
un en pleine concentration à boris neveu
qui veut rejoindre un petit laurent sur
un podium fascinait spassky ça c'est une
affiche enfin bon
ne vendons pas la peau de l'ours avant
de l'avoir tué ici les choses peuvent
être encore bien compliqué
non
qu'est-ce que tu poule peut proposer à
la place de roy et jean luc à la place
de ben wallace la passe de devenir le
petit rock peut-être en f2 mais non
petit roquet et le coup logique non
petit rock et est forcé bon tour des 8es
le four revient donc sur quatre
probablement enfin le cannabis et si non
la prise du cavaly celle ci serait un
aveu stratégique donc un l'aveu de la
dépêche
puisque en donnant la paire de fou dans
ce type de position l'égalité toujours
aucun doute donc christian à jouer roi
f-22 proposé par bertrand oui mais
c'était vraiment un hasard
facebook est sirote c'est marrant
qu'elle est oui l'idée c'est de
surprotéger peut-être le fou le fou et 3
et de jouer un jeu un coup un coup comme
tour b3 peut-être un jour oui mais trois
là christian a peut-être l'intention
d'essayer de jouer pour le match par h 4
h 5
donc il garde sa tour sur la colonne h
c'est une idée originale
curieuse mais original donc tant qu'à
faire sa position stratégique man fait
grise mine
il va essayer de compliqué de compliquer
la position et la partie risque de
devenir fort spectaculaire
voilà donc trois f2
2 le roi c'est ce que vient de dire ça y
est boris termine son développement
autour des 8 temps d hui ils attaquent
le fou et en transparence le pian des 4
il va peut-être jouer suivi par 5 si les
blancs shufu et 4 le coup et cinq en
l'air intéressant donc ça donnerait
peut-être un pion passé
voilà c4 c4 donc question qui qui va
obtenir quelque chose un centre il ya
une idée aussi derrière - f2 c'est que
peut-être après un coup comme eux 6
peut-être que christian aurait
l'intention d'échanger en tout cas
d'essayer d'échanger les dames en jouant
fou prend 6,6 et dames bekaert pour
obtenir une finale qui n'est
probablement pas gagnante mais qui
serait déjà mieux que sa position
ce sera un début en tout cas le dock
leroy f2 qui défense se font trois
donc ces cas tu es là boris réfléchi
peut-être qu'on comprend quand même
c'est vrai que christian a pris a appris
donc à jouer plus vite mais on comprend
peut-être pourquoi ils réfléchissent et
auparavant c'est que pour obtenir une
bonne position dès l'ouverture ce n'est
pas si simple et peut-être qu'il vaut
mieux prendre son temps ça va être le
doute qui va subsister donc de cette
partie
maintenant il faut trouver des cook pour
ce parce qu'il a bien joué au fond il a
trouvé une niche une série de coups une
série d'un plan original
maintenant elle est folle qui il a du
mal à développer ces deux dernières
pièces boris le fou le four c'est 8 et
la tour en 8c son principal problème est
comment il peut bien faire au risque
peut-être jouer dans cette position de
look ou e75 le coût 700 qui est
finalement christian se retrouverait
avec une très très mauvaise une très
très mauvaise structure où ils seraient
obligés de de prendre cinq ou full size
fois aussi surprenant un excellent coup
donc faut aussi ce que se passe-t-il sur
sur ton premier set
bientôt reprendre et c'est dans ce cas
là on prendrait en d'escoffier aussi fou
prend 1,6 qui on prend 1,6 tout reprend
bessette
enfin faut il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses la voilà donc sur foot pro sys
donc puis on prend le 6e tour quand
bessette laboris aurez la possibilité de
jouer donc cavalier à 5 peut-être donc
pour attaquer la tour b 7 et le pion
sekkat qui est un coup intéressant et il
aurait
il aurait d'autres possibilités il
aurait peut-être aussi la possibilité de
jouer damas six pour attaquer cette tour
est pour le pion sekkat bourhis n'avais
pas envie de jouer au sein qui il a
décidé de jouer au fou et 6
il sait que sa position est très très
saine et qu'il peut se permettre de
doubler son pion par ce que il termine
son développement et donc ses pieds se
retrouve face à des cibles donc le pion
des cats et le pion c4 des cibles qui
sont vraiment attaquer directement par
les pièces noires la tour des huit le
fou g7
le cavalier c6 alors bon un pion doublé
au prix de toute cette activité ce n'est
pas grand chose c'est quand même un coup
un coup de très jolis infosys si c'est
bon non oui c'est un coup très jolie
donc tout développement un coup très
sain quand même puisque ça termine le
développement boris donc qu'ils pensent
qu'ils ne doit uniquement faire match
nul donc dans cette position il n'est
pas obligé de chercher donc le conflit
il peut simplement jouer des coups des
coups extrêmement classique et bon quoi
comme poule 6 donc le conflit une
expression favorite de iossif dorfman
qui donc un joueur qui souvent recherche
le conflit n'est ce pas et oui on
cherche souvent le conflit quand on est
en difficulté
voilà bien précises puis on prend 2,6
maintenant on prend 1,6 maintenant on
attend la solution on attend trop prend
bessette
vous tombez 3 aussi peut-être donc
entreprendre et cet énorme a bien sûr
ses positions donc tour pro b cette
peut-être un petit avantage blanc
on ne voit pas pourquoi donc tous
retombés sept cavaliers à 5 peut-être
est très intéressant dame assise comme
tu le signaler tout à l'heure donc après
cavaliers à 5
que se passe t-il aussi si on joue tour
bekkat la torah varembé 8 pour
s'échanger et surtout pompe et 8.8 la
tourneuse de venir en b2 lecavalier
menace de prendre en c4 les noirs ont
des pièces très active
c'est intéressant enfin surtout reprend
bessette si je peux me permettre qu'il
ya six ans le cavalier à 5 on peut faire
c'est pas fait une grosse bêtise
donc tout est contrôlé et mesdames à six
et de toute façon un coup très très
stable très très efficace puisque après
d'âpres en c4 le pion des et d'isoler il
a pris le pion à l'heure donc voilà donc
boris qui va probablement jouer damas
six à moins que tour cette pose des
problèmes
c'est peut-être ce qui peut les ennuyer
donc c'est saturé donne des six tours
c'est cette dame b6 oui maintenant tam à
6 tours c'est cette dame b6 et la tour
est enfermé me semble-t-il
et qu'est ce que vous pensez d'un coup
comme cavaillé prend des cadres suivis
de 5 à damas six voilà donc damas six et
maintenant la question va reposer sur le
coutour bessette b5 peut-être donc la
tour qui remonteraient un petit peu et
qui tiendrait ce pion c4
il ajoute on b5 voilà donc tour b5 et
maintenant cavalier prend des cas voilà
donc boris qui simplifie la position et
donc après une prise éventuelle du
cavalier en d4
les noirs donc vont jouer le coup au 6 e
5 et profiter du clonage pour récupérer
leurs pièces toujours en simplifiant la
position à savoir que le roi et de est
mal placé donc si la position s'ouvre
puisque le roi en f2 et n'est pas trop à
l'abri pour cette position le fou pour
reprendre ici où le cavalier plus tôt et
dans ce cas là se suivre et par 6 5 pour
reprendre sur la case des 4
donc parmi les coûts candidats on peut
analyser peut-être la suite cavaliers
prend des 4 au 5 et l'a peut être tour à
tour b 5 des cinq ne fonctionne pas
peut-être à cause du coût à 6,6 autour
des 5 qui simplifiera là mesdames france
et 4 ne va pas à cause de tout reprend
des huit tours prend des 8 et dames eux
deux ah oui et dames eux deux
effectivement qui gagne une qualité donc
cavalier prend des cartons peu je
cavaliers prend à eux cinq tours d'essai
et au 5e tour des 5 le pronostic pour
l'instant l'enchaînement logique quand
une position qui s'aplanit qui s'aplanit
mais qui reste quand même incertaine
puisque après un échange des pièces
curieusement le roi noir pourrait se
retrouver un petit peu plus ouvert si le
fou g7 disparaissez saddam et non
les cafés chauds tant mieux plus tôt
ainsi d'appréhender vite
mais non
les plus tôt
plus que je
donc voilà
ça se passe pas bien qu'est ce qu'on
peut bien faire avec les ça se passe pas
bien mais pour qui la position revient
incertaine je sais pas qui prend des
quatre n'a pas l'air si simple qu'elle
et prend des cas donc tu dis sur lequel
il prend des quatre ou cinq tours des
cinq tours des cinq dames d'utiliser
dame prend ces quatre noms dame français
4 ne va pas avoir à cause de tout
reprendre et 8 ont produites et dames ne
et tourcoing des caf ou prend d'écarter
les les plans reste avec une qualité de
plus un petit match en cabine
on se pose la question de toute façon
pour le match nous ce qu'on préférerait
ce serait une belle une partie donc un
tie-break en partie rapide en blitz
ce serait excellent pour le spectacle
mais ce n'est pas si simple donc
christian qui doit quand même joué de
sortir une cartouche dans cette partie
pour contrer son adversaire on revient
cela donc sur la variante sur donc
cahier prend dé 4,5 tour des cinq
surtout reprend des cinq surtout pour
des cinq pieds au procès cinq points des
quatre fous prend des cats est alors
faut prendre des quatre dames prend des
quatre dames 3 g iii et on arrive à la
position que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que les noirs ont
échangé leurs fous de cases noires et se
retrouve avec un rock plus affaiblie
donc les blancs ont des compensations
dans cette position ils peuvent
maintenant contrer le jeu des le jeu des
des noirs donc tour b5 un coup
intéressant à jouer donc 5
tout ce qui a été calculé
donc enfin deux variantes qui aurait
selon toi un petit avantage pour les
blancs peut-être mais bon c'est quand
même très compliqué il faudrait regarder
s'il ya pas d'autres possibilités
ah ça y est j'ai trouvé donc j'ai trouvé
une solution très intéressant pour les
noirs c'est que après tour des 5
voorhees va peut-être prendre en d5
prendre andry 4 ensuite avec le pion fou
prend échanger les fous d'un prend des
cats et dames b6 d'un v6 pour transposer
dans une finale deux tours mais il a un
pied en moins il a un pur - donc prête à
lever 6 tours d un pour défendre la dame
et les blancs et le retour des cinq que
penses tu du coup
ce
c'est très difficile pour christian là
qui réfléchit à il a joué tour dans
cette position une possibilité
intéressante
il semble que ce parce qu'il n'est pas
jouer au mieux puisque ab quand même eu
prend des cats c'est quand même
compliqué mais mais maintenant christian
on peut peut-être trouvé du contre je sa
position s'est améliorée c'est ça ne
fait aucun doute
alors qu'autant me signale que christian
bauer ne lui reste plus que six minutes
contre 15 à boris spassky donc c'est
encore une fois christian qui est dans
la panade
il joue vite boris
une un retour à ses 8 et oui toi ces
huit femmes et à l'impression sur le
pion c4 oui il n'est pas obligé de se
précipiter sur ce cavalier en d4 puisque
celui ci reste cloué le cavalier en d4
ne peut pas bouger puisque la dame en d2
serait prise donc il continue à placer
ses pièces et maintenant donc la vente
que j'ai donné tout à l'heure avec tour
des 5 et peut-être plus compliqué
qu'auparavant puisque la tour c 8
pourrait entrer dans l'action
nous vite boris des coups qui font
qu'ils font très mal et oui donc
déplacement efficace un boris finalement
le jeu à la main s'est déplacé ces
pièces sur les cases les plus offensives
et les plus directs avec des menaces
très simple donc l'adversaire doit
forcément doit forcément calculer un
minimum et ce n'est pas si simple que ça
en plus le problème qui s'est posé tout
à l'heure c'est que christian donc n'a
pas joué autour des 5 parce que
finalement cela implique et donc des
décisions techniques assez complexe et
changer toutes les pièces quand on joue
pour le guen ce n'est pas évident
donc voilà donc christian incrusté en
bas de l'écran face à boris
pour ces huit
que va-t-il faire son pion c est faible
on va regarder un petit peu tour des 5
il reste que quatre minutes 34e quelle
est la différence par rapport à tout à
l'heure
la différence c'est que la tour et ans
et 8 donc on peut quand même faire la
même variante c'est à dire tout reprend
dessin et puis on prend des sacs et
prendre en d4
le cavalier et surtout prend des cats
peut-être que là on a des coups miracle
comme par exemple tour ces deux qui peut
être marrant mais qui ne marche pas
parce qu'il ya dame prend ces deux et
surtout prend des quatre échecs le roi
vient en g3 mais on peut peut-être aussi
joué tour ces deux un peu plus tard on
peut jouer fou qu'on des quatre échecs
d'un point d'écart et tour ces deux
échecs et la tour sur la deuxième rangée
quand même n'est pas n'est pas
inoffensives donc probablement tour un
tour ses huit tours c8 un très bon
placement pièce un placement subtil very
very good
là
et christian toujours en réflexion une
réflexion permanente continue wii fit
beaucoup trop loin christian montant il
est déjà dans des sacs
et voilà il joue le coutour des cinq
mais peut-être qu'on prend t-il son
erreur un petit peu tard puisque dans
les échanges vont permettre comme à
boris de rentrer dans la partie puisque
après tout reprend et puis on prend des
quatre est suivi tour ces deux échecs
les noirs ont des contrôles chance
maintenant et boris ne va pas se gêner
pour tout est changé avant les quatre
points des quatre directement oui ça ne
change pas grand chose puisque fou prend
des quatre et plus ou moins forcé et oui
christian qui doit regretter de ne pas
avoir joué ce coup un coût plus tôt
voilà la position s'achemine vers une
égalité au moins voire même un avantage
noir autant tu sais comment ça se passe
voit il reste moins de quatre minutes à
christian bauer
alors petit analyse technique donc
christian va quand même réussir à
affaiblir un petit peu le roi noir mais
malheureusement les pièces de ce parce
qu'ils sont très actives et les tours
vont intervenir aussi donc on peut
envisager après fou après faut prendre
des quatre boris a peut-être un autre
coup c'est d'armes français 4 d'un
procès quatre coins croyable qui cloue
le fou en d4 et qui le mange et qui le
gagne oui oulala ça a l'air d'être donc
fou prend des quatre n'est peut-être pas
possible
et là ça devient vraiment vraiment très
très dur que pense
que faire il reste plus que deux minutes
vers christian bauer entre 14 minutes
un bruit ce parce qu' on peut dire que
boris met une pression terrible autant
non seulement sur l'échiquier mais
autant il a joué ou g5 donc finalement
c'était peut-être la menace de ce pass
qui tout à l'heure avec la tour en a
huit que penses-tu maintenant tout
reprend des cinq suivis de de ce tour en
dessins puis on prend des 58 ces deux
tours prod et 5 euros pour 10 5 suivi de
détroit détroit par darwin
ça semble très très très très
désagréable là quand même
on doit dire c'est que boris est très
impressionnant sur cette partie ne
laisse aucune chance à son adversaire
joue très vite ils jouent très très vite
l'expérience du jeu russe as moins de
deux minutes à christian comment
christian pourrez vous remontez cette
position en moins de deux minutes on
voit pas trop comment
ça paraît très délicat
c'est à boris de réfléchir il faut
prendre tout son temps il a largement il
ya 12 minutes d'avancé maurice est
largement le temps
boris qui a très très bien joué cette
partie donc finalement on s'était trompé
tout à l'heure sur jeu sur sur tourbe et
d5 immédiatement le tour il y avait la
même suite que dans cette partie c'est à
dire c'est à dire plus on prend des
quatre et vous prenez 4 n'était pas
possible tout à l'heure comme maintenant
à quoi ce terme france et 4 un coût qui
nous avait échappé et qui est très très
fort donc boris qui a trouvé l'astuce
il apprend des 5 et voilà le champion
prend et détroit où l'art des trois
menaces ça c'est une menace de plus et
la dame menace pour ces deux quilles
ennahdha mais aussi fou des cats échec
beaucoup de possibilités pour ces deux
qui fait très très mal
c'est sur détroit est un monstre mais
c'est sûr que ça va être fini ça cette
position je veux prouver à ce qu'il peut
faire
la position est sans espoir
en tout cas même si la position d'un
missile crise on arrivait à attirer le
match nul dans cette partie ce ne serait
pas suffisant
il faut qu'ils jouent christian la
trouve un coup il nous reste une minute
trente à christian il est complètement
foutu autant une minute 30 contre 10
minutes à ce pas ce qui c'est terrible
ce qui arrive à christian la première
partie et la seconde il n'a pas réussi à
manager son temps il réfléchit beaucoup
trop faut dire que boris lui a posé de
gros de gros problèmes christian qui
devrait peut-être jeter ses dernières
cartouches par exemple tour 6 pourquoi
pas attaquer la dame dont 6 points 6 50
secondes il reste à christian d'impro 6
ne fonctionne pas donc seconde parce que
sur pure proxis tour ces deux d'un
procès de purpan ces deux le fou g5
revient sur ses seins et on n'a plus
qu'à aller piquer le pion ces deux donc
une cartouche qui peut fonctionner c'est
terrible trente secondes à christian
mais on n'y croit pas trop
il a joué dans le 3
et sa paire le pion à 2 sur l'échec de
prendre le pion à deux avec l'échec de
hugues indécis après le temps des 5
eh oui
c'est très très difficile donc
et oui prend le dessus on a deux bons
ici échec au roi
la dame ici fait échec au roi et à
pouvoir prendre le pion des cinq n'est
joué roger 3 christian et d'en prendre
des 5
ça y est c'est fini boris semble très
satisfait donc de sa position ah oui oui
c'est qui peut plus perdre la main donc
une finale inédite demain donc boris va
jouer contre laurent frayssinet la
finale la grande ionale 10 secondes un
christian il a pris le pion aux 7 et
vous risquerez a rigolé boris a rigolé
six secondes à christian
les jeux à 5 bourhis h4 il reste quatre
secondes à christian donc c'est
quasiment foutu
boris qui replace donc ces pièces pour
mieux sauter on va dire donc le fou est
passé à l' échiquier n'embrasse sur des
six ans passés à l'échiquier réel voilà
dans la food & six f4 c'est fait voilà
avec très beau plein de boris spassky là
on voit la position est complètement
foutu et des deux
voilà le pion des qui va à dame c'est
l'hallali
et oui donc christian la victime du
champion du monde
boris spassky
voilà c'est fini c'est fini victoire de
boris spassky 2 0 donc victoire de boris
spassky les deux joueurs sont en train
d'analyser un petit peu la fin de la
partie avec éventuellement le sacrifice
de tours pour christian enfin la perte
de la tour les conséquences qu'il y
avait mais c'était assez pénible
donc finalement victoire 2 à 0 de boris
spassky deux joueurs sont en train de
l'analyser
on peut regarder un petit peu
apparemment ils sont d'accord sur le
fait que c'était perdant pour les blancs
donc ça paraît logique
donc voilà boris spassky victorieux
toujours pas de commentaire donc de
boris alors que s'est-il passé donc dans
cette journée première demi finale
laurent frayssinet a battu joël lautier
sur le score de 1-1 et demi 1/2 deuxième
demi-finale boris spassky a battu
christian bauer sur le score de 2 0
on voit le beau risque et un style très
rapide donc très très intuitif qui
marche pour l'instant très bien donc
demain à partir de 10 heures et demie si
vous êtes là il y aura la demi-finale
jouait le witch lautier contre christian
bauer et à 14 heures la finale entre
boris spassky et laurent frayssinet donc
le tirage au sort des couleurs pour les
parties n'a pas été fait donc on le fera
demain
merci de nous avoir suivis et je vous
dis à demain si vous revenez